it gives me great pleasure to introduce
professor Proctor and I'm gonna give you
some interesting he's a professor of
history at Stanford and he was born in
Corpus Christi Texas a great-grandson of
a Baptist missionary in China and the
grandson of a Klansman which I found
very interesting he studied biology and
chemistry at Indiana University
following which he obtained his PhD is a
history of science at Harvard where he
taught with Stephen Jay Gould issues of
biology he is the author of some very
interesting books including racial
hygiene medicine under the Nazis cancer
Wars which was made into a four-part PBS
television documentary and value free
science missile terror prize from the
American Public Health Association I
just want to give you a little bit of an
idea of the span of this gentleman's
interest do you mind go ahead that's
fine gemstone aesthetics and the
political history of ignorance actually
these would be this particular lecture
he was the first historian to testify as
an expert witness against the tobacco
industry and he has testified in more
than a dozen of such trials over the
past decade his book on Global tobacco
golden Holocaust origins since that Nazi
background but origins of the cigarette
catastrophe and the case for abolition
will be published by Hubert
well great thank you no that's fine
thank you okay
a lot of ethics is about scale and what
I'm really going to talk today is about
the scale of the global tobacco epidemic
and I just want to begin by noting that
there's six trillion cigarettes smoked
every year worldwide and six trillion is
a pretty big number and just to get you
a sense of how big that is there's every
cigarette is about three inches long and
if you were to put all the cigarettes
smoked every year end to end that would
make a continuous chain enough to go
around the earth around 13,000 times or
enough to reach from the earth to the
Sun and back with enough left over for
several round trips to Mars now that's
admittedly when Mars is in a near-earth
orbit it's this 350 million miles or 320
million miles of cigarettes that's
produced every year that's produced as
if it were a continuous stream of
cigarettes that would be producing
cigarettes at 50 times the speed of
sound in other words you imagine one
continuous rod of cigarettes jetting out
at 50 times the speed of sound or faster
than the rate at which a satellite
orbits the earth so we're talking about
an enormous amount and we're talking
about the leading cause of preventable
death in other words everyone has to die
of something but you don't have to die
from smoking and in fact smoking is what
kills more people than anything else
just in the United States alone around
450,000 people die of cigarettes every
year and just to compare that automobile
accidents now only kill around 30,000
people so we're talking about 12 or 15
times as many people dying from smoking
just in the United States as died from
auto accidents okay now the reason
people die from smoking is because of
What's in cigarettes and if you think
about it if you take the amount of stuff
technically known as crud or that's in
cigarettes and you actually measure it
it and then multiply it by the number of
cigarettes you get an enormous amount of
substance that's actually going
into people's lungs okay we're talking
about just nicotine alone five million
seven hundred thousand kilograms this is
something which if you were to put three
drops of it on your skin it would it
would kill you it's a very powerful
poison
we've got ammonia Crillon nitrile formic
acid ethylene hydrogen cyanide and my
favorite polonium-210 radioactive
polonium the same isotope that killed
the russian spy in london a few years
ago most people don't know it certainly
most smokers don't know it that tobacco
is actually the leading cause of
radioactive exposure to humans and
basically no matter how many times
people say this people still don't know
it but it's actually kind of important
just to give you another sense the
amount of tar that's inhaled if you were
to fill up a railroad car all the way to
the top with 10,000 kilograms of tar
this gooey substance that's really just
content to smoke this would be six
thousand railroad cars filled all the
way to the brim with tar going actually
into lungs now about this is this is
sixty cars here okay so that would be a
hundred of these railroad of these
entire trains placed end to end and
maybe ten percent of that yes oh yeah
it's it actually has two main sources
it's its it comes as fallout on the
Leafs and it attached actually to the
trichomes they're called the sticky
parts of the bottom leaf but it also
comes from the super phosphate
fertilizers that contain uranium that
are mined in Florida and then are used
as substitute for nitrogen fertilizers
now what's interesting about that it's
it's in a lot of other food yeah that's
right but you don't smoke broccoli for
example I mean if you were to smoke
broccoli or peanuts you would probably
also get radical radioactive polonium
but what's important about it in tobacco
is it's completely avoidable in other
words it can be eliminated by four or
five different means and the tobacco
industry has deliberately not removed
because people don't know it's in there
and there's a famous 1978 tobacco
industry memo which says we don't want
to publicize it publicize this because
we don't want a want to wake a sleeping
giant and so people don't know about the
role of polonium and cigarettes okay in
terms of consumption United States is
now about slightly over global average
still for for smoking in fact California
is not that far under the global average
global average six billion people smoke
six trillion cigarettes so for every
person on the planet that's a thousand
cigarettes per person per year average
for the whole world and Greece is high
up there and if we what I want to give
you some sense is actually where tobacco
comes from why it's so widely smoked the
role of the industry and the the what
can be done actually to prevent this the
world's deadliest epidemic there about
70 different species of of tobacco it's
native to the Americas and in fact there
are about 550 Native American images of
tobacco none that we know of that are
linked to pathology but these are
smoking lifts here and this is a tobacco
plant here and you actually get even
cigarettes and cigarettes are just small
cigars but the cigar the the these
little cigarettes that were smoked by
the Maya for over a thousand years prior
to conquest they were very different
from today's cigarettes much less deadly
because they were not generally speaking
inhaled and the reason they were not
inhaled is that the process of curing
was was known as air curing where they
would basically dry the leaves and the
sugar content which starts off at about
25 percent sugar in the tobacco leaf or
polysaccharides these are converted into
these are degraded into only being about
two percent sugar by the time the leaf
is is finished curing
what happens in the 19th century is an
entirely new method of curing is
discovered by accident the story is that
a slave was tending the fires in a
curing barn and the fire went out and so
he rushed out and got some charcoal
instead of wood and this produced a much
hotter fire threw him on the fire
produced a much hotter fire and what it
did is actually destroyed the enzymatic
process that reduces the sugar from 25%
down to 2% it actually trapped the sugar
in the leaf and Prust a sugary golden
leaf that's also known as Virginia
tobacco or colory tobacco or bright
tobacco the key fact about it being that
it is retained the sugar and when you
burn sugars you produce organic acids
and these neutralize the alkaline
alkaloid nicotine and for the first time
in history you're able to inhale
tobacco smoke without coughing and this
is significant it actually was thought
to even be a more healthy form of smoke
in the nineteenth century which was
exactly the opposite of the truth in
other words it produced a much milder
smoke it's pH of a modern cigarette is
around 6.5 versus that of a cigar which
is around 8 or pipe tobacco is around 8
and as a result of this being much
milder much more easier to inhale it's
why cigarettes became sort of known as a
[__] smoke something that kids would
like or females would like it was
actually thought to be milder and the
actual fact was it was far more deadly
because for the first time people
started inhaling in fact the early
tobacco industry encouraged people to
inhale and there were lots of
advertisements to this effect okay so I
want you to remember that I actually
called flu curing the fatal flaw of
cigarette manufacturing if the tobacco
industry wanted to eliminate the global
lung cancer epidemic all they would have
to do is stop the flu curing process and
go back to a pre 19th century method of
curing this is virtually unknown for
some reason it's a kind of a bizarre
fact that's simple one of the many
hidden things about
tobacco okay so flu caring is important
too second factor I'm going to look at
is very quickly it's just the invention
of matches we take making fires for
granted but in fact prior to the 19th
century you had to either rub two sticks
together or use more commonly flint and
steel to start a fire and it actually
took you know 20-30 minutes
typically to start a fire so there's no
way to to you know make an instant fire
and there were fires that had been kept
burning in parts of England for over a
hundred years in the 90s that's where
the expression keep the home fires
burning comes from so it was not a
convenient thing to make fire and this
changes in the 19th century the
invention of friction match matches
phosphorus based matches yellow and then
white and this becomes one of the
reasons that it's convenient to make
fire a third factor is mechanization
cigarettes were all made by hand prior
to the 1880s they were typically made by
girls and women who could roll between
500 and 1500 per day and they each had a
little twist on the end what happens in
the 1880s is a a guy modifies a woolen
carding machine and turns it into the
first cigarette making machine an
automatic cigarette making machine that
was able to crank out a hundred thousand
cigarettes per day so instead of a
thousand per day for these women were
hand rolling a hundred thousand it
dramatically lowered the cost of
production buck Duke of the American
tobacco company gotta essentially a
monopoly on the machines for a time
dropped the price and cigarettes
transitioned from being a luxury an
occasional luxury to a very cheap
consumer product and this is just the
beginning in terms of mechanization
almost no one pays attention to this
because we tend to have what I call a
kind of consumer sovereignty view about
tobacco we all basically say okay
cigarettes everyone should be able to
buy them but then we should try to
convince everyone not to buy them and
almost no one looks at the factories
cigarettes are made they're not
smoked probably few people in this room
can even imagine what the inside of a
cigarette factory looks like they tend
to be invisible most people don't even
know where the cigarette factories are
but these machines these are the
deadliest machines in the history of
human civilization producing the
deadliest artifact in the history of
human civilization cigarettes killed
only a hundred million people in the
20th century but they're on the pace now
to kill a billion people there's no
doubt that the cigarette epidemic is
primarily in the future the most common
ideology and myth about smoking is that
it's something about the past in fact if
you look at a lot of the food politics
that's going on now they'll often say
well we need one to do to two to fast
food well what we did to tobacco like
we've solved the tobacco problem the
fico problem hasn't been solved it's a
problem of the future not of the past
though probably will be ten times as
many deaths from smoking in the future
as there have been in the past and
that's partly because of these machines
which can produce 20,000 cigarettes per
minute okay that's a lot of cigarettes
okay and as a result the amount of
smoking just in the United States has
increased enormously from around two
million cigarettes in 1869 1900 you've
got about two billion cigarettes smoked
and it doesn't peak until the early
1980s at around six hundred and thirty
billion cigarettes okay so that's
falling now in the United States
globally it's actually about flat I
actually think that probably we've
already passed peak cigarette sort of
like Peak Oil you know six trillion
cigarettes is actually probably I think
the peak and actually China I think will
actually be one of the first countries
to ban cigarettes bhutan has already
banned them sort of them in some sense
but i think actually the trend is going
to be downward but the problem is the
20-year time delay 30 or
delay between exposure and disease which
means that even if no one stops no one
smokes anymore cigarettes after today
there still will be millions of deaths
from from cigarettes okay now just
looking at lung cancer lung cancer is
not the main way people die from smoking
but it's sort of the signature disease
90 to 95 percent of all lung cancers in
a country like the United States are
caused by smoking 160,000 per year this
would be a tenth of that or less if it
were not for smoking it might even be a
twentieth of that and that too has
increased lung cancer was so rare around
the time of the first world war the
doctors when they would find a case they
would show their students hey look at
this disease this disease you may never
see another case in your whole career it
was extremely rare and now it's by far
and away the most common cause of cancer
death and men and women and this is the
sort of structure of the per capita
consumption of cigarettes which has its
ups and downs due to social forces war
has always been a big promoter of
smoking and World War one cigarettes are
given free to the soldiers cigarettes
were actually banned in 15 states in the
United States that's another thing
people don't realize is that the
individual states actually have the
power to ban cigarettes and that's been
upheld by the Supreme Court
it actually was part of the prohibition
movement nicotine next World War two
cigarettes were also given out to the
soldiers in World War one you had an
entire generation of doughboys coming
home from the war addicted to tobacco
World War two the same thing happened
these guys are lighting their cigarettes
on the on the machine redhot machine gun
but what most people don't realize even
historians of the Marshall Plan don't
realize that cigarettes were a big part
of the Marshall Plan the what happened
was 16 governments that were to receive
Marshall Plan aid after World War two
met together in Paris and wrote up a
list of what they needed and tobacco was
not on that list
big mistake and as a result this guy
senator Willis Robertson who's Pat
Robertson's father by the way
the televangelists he wrote it into the
bill saying that you know we've really
got to get tobacco moving into Europe
and as a result for every $2 in food
that was sent to Europe as part of the
Marshall Plan that was one dollar in
worth of tobacco and this is probably
the largest export of cancer that had
occurred in the world up to that time
but in any event it was important in
actually international relations from
that point on now one reason that
cigarettes prosper is what I call a
conflict of interest or double addiction
governments are massively addicted to
the revenues the tax revenues that come
from cigarettes cigarettes are very easy
to tax they're homogeneous radically
homogeneous in fact they're storable
preservable they're their point source
produce so you can take the factory and
put the stamp on at the factory they're
centralized distributed and so they're
an excellent thing to to tax and
throughout the world
whereas Health Ministry's deplore
tobacco Finance Ministry's love it and
in fact in some parts of the world
cigarettes have been a major part of
governmental revenues when I first
started working on tobacco publishing on
this in the 1990s lecturing on this
China was getting 12% of its entire
state budget was just from tobacco taxes
now they've become wealthy and it's only
about seven and a half percent but still
this is a major fraction of their entire
economy in the United States in the
1880s a third of the entire federal
income was from tobacco taxes did you
have a question
it's taxing the consumer but of course
the you know that means that the costs
go up for for cigarettes so it's it has
an effect on theoretically and
depressing consumption the price
elasticity of of tobacco tax is about
0.4 and so for every 10% increase in
price you get about a point four
decrease point you know about a four
percent decrease in the consumption so
it's it's fairly inelastic because of
addiction but what it means is you have
a conflict of interest throughout the
world even what most people don't
realize is even in Nazi Germany about
ten percent of the entire state of Nazi
Germany was financed just by tobacco
taxes two thirds of the entire
brownshirt movement the stormtroopers
the brown shirts support up thailand two
thirds of that was supported just by
tobacco taxes they had their own brand
of cigarettes the storm cigarettes the
front cigarettes alarm cigarettes so
this has been a deep conflict of
interest for quite quite some time now
China is becoming or has already become
the leading consumer from a country
point of view because there's so many
Chinese and about a third of the world's
cigarettes are now produced slightly
actually over a third of the world
cigarettes are produced in China third
of the world cigarettes are consumed and
it will kill about 1/3 of all young
Chinese men now alive about one in three
and possibly even more than that ok so
now what I want to turn to I mean how
did this how did this get going I've
mentioned the the the machines I've
mentioned the flu curing which makes it
inhalable I've talked about matches
talked about the importance of Wars and
and Finance for governments but there's
also mass marketing mass marketing is is
essential because cigarettes it's not a
natural thing for people to smoke it's
not an easy thing most people's first
encounter with cigarettes is nausea
how do you make something that's you
know poisonous and very unpleasant into
something that's that's very popular and
mass marketing was certainly key to this
the some of the best minds of
hucksterism were were hired by the
tobacco industry and a lot of our modern
forms of marketing were actually
invented by the tobacco industry the
tobacco industry invented baseball cards
for example as stiffeners in packs and
so now you can buy cigarette card albums
that would include these cards and these
are everything from famous movie stars
to athletes to birds of the world or
flags of the world or in Germany there's
entire albums just devoted to Adolf
Hitler or to the German army or
different types of Tanks and so this
becomes very very popular and this was
this was used to sell cigarettes
skywriting was invented by the tobacco
industry is not so common anymore but
when I was growing up you would see in
the sky there would be this jet trail
that the biplanes would be carving out
letters and in 1923 over Times Square
the very first spelling out of Lucky
Strike means fine tobacco you know in
these mile-high letters was done okay
many other forms of the the tobacco
industry sometimes even had baseball
teams as the Chesterfield satisfiers
named after the slogan for Chesterfield
cigarettes some of the brands that were
produced at this time were were racist
by the World War one there were 30,000
different brands in in use in cigarettes
these were much more locally diverse
than they would later become but you had
[__] head tobacco here advertised you
had somebody called [__] hair tobacco
now this is something that was smoked
only in the northern part of the United
States by the way in the 1930s there
were
about 400,000 pounds of [__] hair
tobacco smoked every year just in
Milwaukee and this lasted for quite some
time in 1942 they changed the name to
bigger hair tobacco and this went went
on and they also added a little thing on
the side you it's hard to read this is
Fiji Islander so they transformed it
into a a Fiji Islander this was actually
sold on into into the nineteen nineteen
sixties other forms of racism and brands
that were sold in Europe or here you had
a brand that was said to be made by
clean healthy girls not Japs or Chinamen
a lot of other type of imagery the
cigarette is radically homogeneous but
branding and naming is able to make it
heterogeneous so you're able to turn a
cigarette into a female cigarette like
Virginia Slims and it seems like it
essentially a female cigarette whereas
actually in Korea all Virginia Slims are
smoked by males and that seems odd but
it's just a cigarette you know but how
does it acquire this this gender you had
erotic cigarettes you had life
cigarettes and peace cigarettes I
actually brought some long life
cigarettes here from from China
you've got death cigarettes sold in
Japan you've for a time I thought you
might not be able to find religious
themed cigarettes but and I'm not sure
why you'd want Three Nuns in your pipe
anyway to begin with but you have
revelation brand tobacco you've got
dozens of different sports branding in
cigarette packs the packs are a form of
micro advertising by the way and that's
one reason there's such a push to make
plain branded packs you know with no
coloring at all it's just just the
warnings the visual warnings and the
tobacco industry was sometimes worried
about children using it and so they
would you know they didn't want
children under the age of six to be
using these type of products so there
was a certain level of social
responsibility that has been mentioned
there there were Listerine cigarettes
there's more doctors smoke camels and
what you'll also notice here my
colleague Rob jackler pointed out it's
not by accident that the M and the D are
in red and the iconography is
sophisticated in a lot of these things
the child says I'm going to grow a
hundred years old and I guess smoking
camels is going to be recommended for
that this is also true in Japan doctors
were used to advertise cigarettes in the
1950s it wasn't just that there was
radioactivity and cigarettes sometimes
extra radioactivity was was added if
they weren't radioactive enough so these
were radium brand cigarettes
you also have Nazi cigarettes here you
have communist and non-communist
cigarettes popular see Pachuca and here
you have like the dog the first dog in
space he's got his own brand of
cigarette he didn't didn't make it back
from space by the way alive and this one
yeah and this one is Sputnik here it's a
Sputnik the first artificial satellite
you have labor cigarettes and you have
snooty cigarettes
you have Harvard cigarettes and you have
Princeton cigarettes and of course you
have Stanford cigarettes this is
frightening from the 20s around the time
of World War one the motto I guess is
dilute as a box of eight so this is it's
actually murad cigarettes celebrating
Stanford yeah Berkeley cigarettes you
have cigarettes for presidents the
presidential vehicles used to all have
their own cigarettes campaign cigarettes
as well you have cigarettes for
prisoners these are official cigarettes
of the Florida Division of Corrections
you have true cigarettes and you have
fictional cigarettes and you have candy
cigarettes and I've done a fair amount
of work in the history of candy
cigarettes they're interesting because
brown and Williamson tobacco company and
a number of the others tolerated brand
infringement because as the lawyer for
Brandon Williams said put it in a secret
document they were not too bad in
advertisement and in fact the Brown &
Williamson company tolerant not only
tolerated the brand infringement but
actually sent the plates for the art for
their actual cigarette packs to the
candy cigarettes companies so that the
candy cigarettes would be made in
realistic imagery of the actual
cigarette and some of these for example
this is one of my favorite this is
Harvard brand candy cigarettes and the
message is pretty clear just like Daddy
okay so training in gestures for a
future addiction you can find cigarettes
for the doll for your dollhouse
cigarette trick books by the RJ Reynolds
company cigarette cookbooks Marlboro
Cook's like a man the last last meal art
form
and this is part of a type of what we
sometimes call brand stretching the idea
was if we can keep even if we're not
allowed to advertise directly cigarettes
we could produce Marlboro clothing or
Marlboro keychains here these are
cigarette charms here people would wear
brands stretching Marlboro classics a
line of clothing that was supported by
the tobacco industry in order to keep
the word Marlboro around even though
it's not describing Marlboro cigarettes
it's describing marvel clothing but it's
to keep Marlboro in the minds of people
even travel agents the peter stuyvesant
that's a popular European brand of
cigarette a travel agency established
with the Peter Stuyvesant name to
promote that brand of cigarette
the imagery is sometimes very
interesting at times there have been
bands actually on the use of
personalized figural imagery and the
tobacco industry has been very clever in
personalizing actual physical cigarettes
to get around the band I'll show you an
example of that in a moment
but you have cigarettes portrayed as
love here the diamond going on ring of
the woman from the smoke ring now you
have cigarettes essentially as porn here
we have kiss natural tobacco I just let
you sort of absorb that those images for
a moment
in other words figural images are denied
but then the tobacco industry is very
clever and getting around that ban some
of the most interesting are the European
silk cut ads which again with the ban on
showing physical imagery they're able to
have very subtle iconography here of a
single slit so silk and cut so silk and
silk cut as a brand of a gala her brand
of of tobacco and these are very very
rich the imagery here so what's going on
with us here this is silk cut alright so
what is it it's a that's a what is it
it's a can-can yeah it's a can-can you
know sexual imagery you know vagina
dentata or whatever or this one I like
to collect cactus I'm fond of this one
silk and cut or this one is this sort of
you got a Venus Fly Trap eating your
trousers silk cut or this one or this
one you know anything that will draw
your fascination you know something with
the Frog and the and the spaceship here
over this one what does this one say you
know kiss a camel or this one what does
this one say
when do in do you light up a camel when
you're waiting for the bus a lot of a
camel when you're waiting for the bus
right so a lot of very subtle imagery
basically the tobacco industry
outclasses the public health community
by a factor of many something very
similar right very simple very simple
imagery they're able to capture the Red
Hot Chili Peppers and cigarettes has
freedom this was a an ad I pulled out of
a European news week in the 1990s and it
portrays a smoking section
traditional Amsterdam Jewish quarter
actually representing smokers
essentially as Jews and therefore the
implication that critics of smoking are
like Nazis and this playing the Nazi
card has been a very common theme in in
a whole series of advertisements by the
tobacco industry or the democracy will
talk about smokers being lynched or
stigmatized or forced to sit at the back
of the bus and this has been very
effective to capture this liberal
rhetoric of freedom and in fact smoking
for a time in the 1980s and 1990s was
really identified as a form of free
speech as a form of speech and Philip
Morris funded the American Civil
Liberties Union to defend smoking as a
form of freedom in the workplace a kind
of a quid quo pro arrangement so here a
Virginia Slims ad find your voice you
know smoking is your voice Express you
know cigarette is the form of expression
and females have been a targeted a
number of different ways through sports
in 1920s one of the earliest campaigns
to target women was to say you know you
women should smoke in order to avoid
avoid weight gain and there's been this
play on certain types of cigarettes as
diet cigarettes slims or thins or skinny
cigarettes as diet cigarettes as if a
fat cigarette would make you
fad somehow I mean I mean if smoking
actually lowers your weight then
theoretically you'd want a lot of smoke
but in any event another technique has
been the funding of women's tennis and
in fact Billie Jean King was someone who
Co promoted with Phil Morrison
eventually joined the Philip Morris
Board of Directors in the 1990s and
here's her signature Billie Jean King
right on a coupon for cigarettes and she
allowed in her magazine women's sports
she allowed Philip Morris to advertise
cigarettes cigarettes is gifting rituals
smoking in space yeah you know you have
a Sigourney Weaver in the first scene of
Avatar smoking says where's my who's got
my goddamn cigarette you know in this
oxygen enriched environment in the year
2150 to this environmental scientist
female is smoking I don't think so
but animate do you have all kinds of
interesting imagery like this here if
the apocalypse is coming you should grab
your cigarettes and jump into the
chamber German add some weird things
going on with the Hat here and you know
some people say if the cigarette is up
it's maybe before sex if it's down it's
after sex you have these little elves
doing something I'm not sure what in any
event there's all kinds of interesting
iconography going on even in the
advertisements here and Philip Morris
actually sent out these supposedly
anti-smoking or youth prevention smoking
ads in the year 2000 sent out to
thousands of American high schools and
here you have this the person who's
supposed to think not smoke and of
course that's exactly what teenagers
like is to stand apart from the crowd
and people have different
interpretations of what this snowboard
might mean this certainly is not tobacco
this wouldn't be menthol and that
wouldn't be smoke and I'm not sure what
the actual snowboard is but there's a
whole series of these Lorillard all
so did a theme tobacco was Wakko if
you're a teen the guy with the butt chin
here the sort of school teacher balding
guy not necessarily someone that kids
would identify with or here you
another's from this same one this woman
with the with the man hands tobacco is
Wakko if you're a teen again these are
funded by tobacco companies supposedly
as anti tobacco ads but you can
interpret them differently tobacco is
wack out if you're a teen if you're a
teen I guess if you're not a teen it's
not whacko the iconography has again
been very interesting here's a Reynolds
right decisions right now you have
basically the Reynolds version of the
Marlboro Man he's the smoker he's he's
the who's the cool guy right so you've
got this guy you know he's cool here
he's watching The Horizon
this guy's got a his cap on backwards
how cool is that he can't even reach the
game they're playing a game he can't
even reach the game he's standing on
tiptoes he's to he's much he's younger
than this guy this guy's a flat top
which is I guess is the cool style for
kids and so you've got all kinds of
interesting iconography that goes on now
I'm not sure this one is as complicated
in the symbolism the symbol the the
sports sponsorship has been enormous in
the tobacco industry and I'm also not
totally sure which brand is being
advertised here it could be Marlboro
Philip Morris becomes the leading
sponsor of sports in the 1990s and does
this globally I it's almost impossible
to find a sport that has not been funded
by the tobacco industry globally is all
over the world at Malaysia Australia
Africa Formula One racing has been
heavily supported and here we have the
Marlboro Ferrari car they
changed it when they weren't supposed to
be advertising in Formula one they did a
barcode design so you went from this to
this so they could say well we don't
actually have the word Marlboro on it
and this is its kind of Marlboro light
or something like that an image of
Marlboro so the imagery was was played
with and it has heptad weight films have
become the number number one form of of
getting people to smoke Sylvester
Stallone was offered a $500,000 to smoke
Brown & Williamson brands and his films
many different movies have had film
plants plugs and them Philip Morris paid
three hundred fifty thousand dollars to
have large featured in the the Bond
thriller license to kill Superman to has
around 20 implants and this one scene
Philip Morris paid twenty thousand
British pounds where Christopher Reeves
breaks through a billboard on the side
of a truck to save the world and if you
actually go back and watch Superman -
from the point of view of tobacco
advertising it's actually very
interesting and this is spread
throughout the world
Hollywood is about 5% of American
business exports it's one of our few
really great industry exports and
tobacco has been a central feature of
that and it's one reason that people
think that smoking is kind of a
progressive American thing to do even be
actors have sometimes been plugging
cigarettes a lot of the advert the
advertising that was done for cigarettes
the actors eventually would die from
them
I hear Betty Grable Spencer Tracy Edie
Sullivan these are sort of voices from
the past but the number of jazz
musicians died of smoking and this is
just some of the the deaths that's
what's interesting is how recent a lot
of these are because again the the
long delayed delayed effects the tobacco
industry has mounted a campaign of
deception this has been recognized in
federal courts really it's the world's
deadliest conspiracy launched in 1953 to
hide the hazards of smoking and this is
the magna carta of that conspiracy the
so-called frank statement where they
denied that had been proven to cause
hazards and then went on to deny this
repeatedly thereafter and the motto
really was doubt as our product one of
the things i do is study the history of
ignorance and this is a quintessential
example people don't know things for a
reason if you don't know there's
polonium and cigarettes that's because
you haven't been taught maybe the
tobacco industry used doubt manipulated
doubt and had many different methods of
creating doubt including doubt and
ignorance even in its own employees so
there's something i call internal agna
tala g that i'm working on now which is
the fact that the tobacco industry
actually lied to its own employees about
the hazards of smoking it censored
health brochures and it included the
same sort of denialist apparatus but the
cigarette itself i think in terms of
design it's one of the most carefully
designed small objects in the history of
america and the world
billions and billions of dollars have
gone into cigarette design chemical
manipulation in order to strengthen the
force of the nicotine impact a number of
other things filters one of the many
ways in which cigarettes are deceptive
okay so let me then just come to this
general conclusions it's not a natural
thing for people to smoke it people
smoke as a result of social forces these
include flu curing which made cigarettes
inhalable and therefore
far more deadly than they otherwise
would have been when I called the fatal
flaw matches made fire mobile
transportable it's the sort of
bureaucratic lifestyle of centuries and
were and people with idle hands fit very
easily into this smoking market
mechanization made cigarettes profoundly
cheap it's basically a form of printed
paper wrapped in paper a taxation made
cigarettes attractive to government and
as a result governments throughout the
world encouraged tobacco are they in
China today there may be 15 people whose
job it is to prevent people from smoking
tobacco control advocates there may be
15 million people whose job is is to
keep people smoking as much as possible
including the farmers so the ratio is
about a million to one there's something
wrong with that wars have made
cigarettes popular the hazards ignore
mass marketing is made smoking
attractive and sexy and now this is
going on going on globally mass
deception has made cigarettes survival
in the imagination but we also have a
Rina raishin of cigarettes the story of
cigarettes is being told by people who
are not totally disinterested my
interest is I'm an advocate I consider
myself an advocate for the truth and an
advocate for health but they're also
large numbers of people who are working
for the tobacco industry and have been
paid to become advocates including here
at Stanford and it's not widely known in
fact I regard it as possibly the most
serious abuse of academic integrity
since the Nazi period the capturing of
academic intellectuals by the tobacco
industry its massive and and generally
unexplored and that reen aeration that
they provide allows it to become
survivable in court now I want to close
them with a just a quote from
Hippocrates and searching for the
obscure do not overlook the obvious we
don't have to have cigarettes
I think eventually we will not have
people smoking cigarettes and I think
actually probably much of the impulse
will of that will come from
environmental reasons cigarettes are the
major cause of fires they are a
significant contributor to global
warming through the production process
the enormous amount of resources that
are used and as people start becoming
more worried about global warming which
will probably happen right people will
start looking for things than our
overindulgent lifestyles to cut out and
cigarettes will be a pretty easy one to
drop out okay we're going to have more
warnings but again we don't need only
warnings we need to actually go to the
productive process itself simple
solutions that could actually even been
done within present law in the United
States the FDA is empowered to regulate
the content of cigarettes now and they
have the power to reduce nicotine
content to below 1 milligram per
cigarette present-day cigarettes have
all about 10 to 12 milligrams of
nicotine in the rod if you were to take
this and lower it by a factor of 10 or
20 cigarettes would not be capable of
sustaining addiction and they would no
longer become addictive the other thing
you could do is raise the pH of tobacco
smoke go back up to 8 or above and that
would essentially end the lung cancer
epidemic